tonight uh we're going to be one third
of the distance between Earth and the
Sun
and it's at its brightest the distance
is 43 million kilometers it has an orbit
of 50 000 years which means it was last
seen during the era of the niator Dolls
it has a velocity of 57 kilometers per
second
its appearance is green because of its
composition
it has diatomic carbon and cyanogen
which make it appear green the
government as approaches some
meets solar radiation and solar wind
therefore two tails are formed the first
tail is the dust tail that is along the
movement of the comment and the second
tail is the iron gas tail that heads
towards always bore with the sun tonight
while the comet is at its minimum
distance from the earth about 42
millions of kilometers there is also a
very bright moon up there in the sky
just spreading its huge natural light
all around and it is of course strongly
affecting observation so it is far from
being ideal the condition we have over
[Music]